well this is gonna be on the internet
forever this is the first time I'm ever
going to put on a speedo yeah I've never
in my life thought about wearing a
speedo thought what I'd look like
wearing a speedo or anything of that
nature and I think of someone wearing a
speedo it's usually there's like the
really hot guy like the one who's like
super fit like abs are like the V
clearly pointing to their penis like
some Italian guy over in some beach in
Europe because that's what I see in the
movies at least then there's like the
old guy like banana hammocks that's
that's cool oh boy I don't know about
this oh damn this is gonna be real but
maybe I'll wear these for drag they're
gonna be a good touching painting is
speedo time they're not oh my god oh my
god but no great Apple expose right now
I can't even find ya I feel like I'm
pretty close to Newton so it's real
I'm done
this is I can't really wait a thing
about feel honestly the only gonna do
this other beats online confident but
this isn't this is a lot I have a 100%
like level increase of respect for
anybody who wears these and lovely
because you have to be very confident
like feel like I'm naked right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I feel pretty good like I feel like this
is what people have to do before they
wear speedos to the beats you got to get
in the mirror you got a gotta flex your
muscles and just show yourself that you
are worthy of this B go after like walk
around it I feel sexy I feel good you
know feel good about myself
I want to wear this the rest of the
mornings for you it is pretty good yeah
just you know go for it
forget about it you know leaning to you
it is just something so fun about
letting go it doesn't matter what anyone
else thinks as long as in my mind I'm
like I feel later know somebody's gonna
add that to this thing
[Music]
[Music]